You probably agree that opt-in with
patient specified restrictions
is the most attractive
privacy consent model.
But how do you actually manage it?
How do patients indicate what data
they want to share or not share?
Providing a mechanism is
the data segmentation problem.
Suppose for
example a patient had hypertension and
depression among their medical problems.
Their hypertension is
not well controlled and
they have undesirable side effects
from the drugs prescribed to treat it.
So they're interested in joining
a clinical trial for a new and
promising medication.
As a result,
they want to share the hypertension part
of their data to apply for the trial.
But they are sensitive
about their depression and
wish to restrict access to that data.
How do they specify that?
The solution is easier if someone with
clinical expertise and their trust,
such as their physician,
does it for them.
But suppose the patient has their
record in a PHR and wants to apply for
the trial themselves.
Presented with a list of their own
medications, they may not recognize
the names or know for
sure which ones are for what condition.
That form of sharing would be
greatly facilitated if their PHR or
EMR understood these
clinical relationships.
Here's a simple depiction of just
such a record for our hypothetical
patient from Dr. Jonathan Nebeker at
the University of Utah in the Utah VA.
Given this underlying
representation of relationships,
the patients could simply
click on hypertension and
see the related medications
with the others greyed out,
greatly facilitating the opt-in with
patient-specified restrictions model.